and i kind of broke your 11 year old
heart i didn't take a picture with you
and i was like oh i feel crummy i feel
jojo i'm so sorry i'm so sorry and she
was like it's seriously not a big deal
but i do remember that candace cameron
beret apologizes to jojo siwa after jojo
called cameron the rudest celebrity
she's ever met
all good on the jojo front and now
there's no bad blood between the stars
that's what is amazing about social
media candace gives the full backstory
on instagram honestly i was shocked when
i saw the tick tock on sunday yeah so
were we you'll recall jojo jumped on the
ticksock trend where users quickly
flashed photos of celebs and categorize
them one of the topics rudest celebrity
i've ever met and that's when jojo calls
out candice
what did i do to you and thankfully now
we know
she said you know i met you at the
fuller house premiere and i was 11 years
old
and we were all on the red carpet
and when i had i had come up to you and
i said can i have a picture with you and
you
said to me
not right now
let's rewind easy was at that premiere
chatting it up with a cast including
candice
i've heard nothing but great feedback
well except from one fan and i go and i
kind of broke your 11 year old heart i
didn't take a picture with you and i was
like oh i feel crummy i feel
jojo i'm so sorry i'm so sorry and she
was like it's seriously not a big deal
but i do remember that but as candace
tells it jojo has a new take on the
moment years later and she's like yeah
no no you weren't even mean and she goes
and i get it now as an adult
when you're on the red carpet and
everything's happening and you're being
pulled in different directions and yet
candace admits there's still one reason
she feels bad about how it went down and
i said okay i said but please know
especially as a mom
uh it breaks my heart that i made you
feel that way and
and i'm sorry to your mom too that i did
that to her daughter because
i know if anyone crosses my kids like
mama bear comes out but one thing's for
certain candice didn't lose a fan in the
process
and she said she still loves watching
full house and watches it to like fall
asleep and it's a comfort show for her
so we had all the feels and it was all
good and there's like
there's no drama um that's the t candice
then wraps up with the takeaway about
the influence of social media
so that was it all good all good on the
jojo front and i you know i think the
lesson that we can learn is to
to be mindful that no matter
how many followed followers you have you
know even a 10 second
trending tick tock video
can do damage because our words matter
and our actions matter we
all influence the people around us
[Music]
you